so
cnn is doing their conference call with
all their reporters and everybody
he got the number to the conference call
for the last two months they've recorded
every single one of cnn's calls
led by cnn's president and ceo yeah
and watch what happens press play
washington
you're unneeded hey jeff zucker are you
there
hey this is james o'keefe we've been
listening to your cnn calls for
basically two months uh recording
everything
um just wanted to ask you some questions
if you have a minute
do you still feel you're the most
trusted name and news because i have to
say from what i've been hearing on these
phone calls
i don't know about that we've got a lot
of recordings that indicate
you're not really that uh independent of
a journalist
okay um thank you for uh thank you for
uh your comments um so everybody in
light of that i think what we'll do is
we'll
we'll set up a a new system and we'll uh
we'll be back with you
we'll do the rest of the call a little
bit later we're gonna release those
recordings today
at seven o'clock so stay tuned it's
gonna be fun with everybody have a good
day
you too so um you just heard me talk to
uh
uh the president of cnn jeff sucks
they're still listening to him
he hasn't hung up that we are going to
release
a number of recordings today i unmuted
myself into the conference line
and they're still on there they're
listening to me right now
okay stop it at this point stop it at
this point
okay uh so so what were we talking about
a minute ago before i went into this
we're talking about voter fraud but what
was i talking about after voter fraud
bill bar all these guys that are saying
what they're saying okay so
you got a channel like
cnn who gets on a call like this and
zucker tells them what to talk about
i said to you i'm interested in one
thing you know what's the one thing i'm
interested in
here's what i'm interested in i want to
know who held that meeting
with all the leaders of the democratic
party and said here's how we
steal the election the way you steal the
election
is by shutting down the economy bring
out mail-in ballots
mail-in ballots are not controlled with
voter id this is how we're able to steal
it
this is how we win the election whoever
came out with that strategy
that's who has the power
that's the most influential person in
that party
who that person is i don't know if it's
obama i don't know if it's hillary
i definitely don't think it's tom perez
i want to know who that person is
because that's the person that gets
credit for this election not biden
so you're wrapping that all up to say it
was some strategic thinking
basically saying we're going to shut
down the economy oh we're going to do
mail-in buddies
and we're going to there's still this
election there is no listen
is it fair to say both sides use
propaganda yes is it fair to say
republicans use propaganda democrats use
propaganda
yes would you agree on that yes yes or
no yes okay
so guess what happens whoever has the
better strategy wins
and you got to give it to them yeah the
democrats had a better strategy
right politics is a dirty game oh you
know it's probably not a high profile
person
it was somebody behind the scenes where
the genius people are think what whoever
it was it's interesting
but real quick tom when
is it fair to say that attorney general
william barr bill barr
has had trump's back harder than anyone
basically other than me he was just
doing his job
question secretary because he had his
back sure so when he comes out and says
look
i would love to tell you otherwise but
we could not find he's the the attorney
general
yeah leads the department of justice we
could not find any voting fraud
that would sway this election is that
credible to you he said yet
i mean that doesn't mean the
investigation is over doesn't mean the
doj isn't involved now
but after that moment because he was
probably answering the question for
the moment have you found anything are
you saying right now no i
don't have a three-hour meeting
yesterday by the way if you're listening
if you're listening to this and if you
think something like that happened
behind closed doors a strategic thing
like that happened behind closed doors
uh uh uh push the thumbs up button if
you think something happened if you
think nothing like that happened and it
was just lost
push the thumbs down button i'm curious
to know what you think right now we got
248 to 17. i'm curious to know what you
think but going back to what you're
saying the bar
yeah bart did say that there is i have
another prediction sure go ahead because
where is it getting and our friend um
tom ellsworth
said this the other day pelosi is my
guest good mother said she thinks it's
pelosi
i don't think she's smart i don't
i think it's somebody that's brilliant
behind closed doors here's my prediction
where is it getting uglier than anywhere
right now what state
where is it getting uglier than anywhere
it's georgia
georgia yeah getting super ugly what is
the current
you know what's going on in the current
atmosphere in georgia right now i'll
tell you what's going on
um brian kemp who's the governor of
georgia let's just start there
he is a lifelong republican he ran on
trump make america great again he put on
the red hat he is trump trump trump
trump trump
he came out and basically said look
we've done the we've done the votes
we've done the recount it's a hand
recount
brace yourself biden won brian kemp
so now you have uh sydney powell trump's
legal team going down there stirring up
the base
yeah getting all sorts of nonsense
they're basically going out and saying
you can't trust the system don't vote in
this election i don't know if you've
heard that
she's basically encouraging people not
to vote in georgia no and
yeah no she's not dude tom like we could
find her quote right there
easily she's based saying you can't
trust this it's all rigged you can't
trust it
now you have the repub it's all
republicans of georgia that run the
congress
the house of representatives in georgia
have you seen this in passion speech
that the republican
election official made uh yesterday he's
basically saying somebody's gonna get
killed
you got people showing up basically
threatening people one of our people at
the election officials republicans by
the way what's your point i end up with
the news
here's my prediction yeah if where's
that shirt what's your point already
we got to get that yeah
if you asked me a week ago i would say
there's no chance that republicans are
not going to at least get one
possibly two of those seats in georgia
at this current climate
just be careful how you act be careful
what you wish for because if you keep
acting like this
if you keep saying a rigged election if
you keep telling your base not to vote
you can't be trusted
you're gonna end up losing two seats in
georgia and the worst is yet to come
i'm hoping i'm and i'm being honest here
i'm hoping that at least one republican
wins
so you can keep the the house and senate
in check with biden and it's not just
democrat democrat democrat
but you keep acting like this you're
going to lose two seats and it's going
to get very ugly i jump in here you said
i was wrong on buying somebody i won
that
people owe me one more time it is a kid
you also said that i was wrong on biden
okay listen
okay what's going on week left it's
propaganda what's going on in georgia
right now it is a coordinated
effort to fake the voters into thinking
they shouldn't vote there's hollywood
stars
that are doing it right now they're
doing a twitter campaign stacy abrams is
leading this whole charge
they're trying to they're trying to have
you seen the tweet the video
tweets okay they're they're saying hey
write in
president trump so he can get those
crony get those crony bastard democrats
out of there write him in
as the uh as a writing candidate for
georgia senate
i mean they are playing as dirty way
dirtier now to try to get these last
seats in georgia than they were in the
presidential election
so look at the stuff that's going on the
repub they're doing fake radio
advertisements they're doing billboards
they're trying to get republicans not to
vote
so they don't get the seat let's just
use the republic let's use sydney
powell's words let's use
the georgia election official
a couple people just trump's saying it's
embarrassing that he voted for brian
kemper brian kemp supported him these
are republicans
and fighting go ahead you were going to
say something about oh no it's just it's
so scary what's going on in georgia
and um they're they're not i mean the
amount of money that's being poured into
there the stakes
that you know what could happen mark
cuban i saw tweet from mark cuban
uh about three weeks ago he says for all
these people that are putting all their
money into georgia rather than putting
the money into the campaign contribution
why don't you give it to a family i'm
like wait what
yeah local uh charity i'm like what do
you mean local charity that's a very
strange recommendation
so what do you mean don't give the money
to the funds
in georgia rather give it to local
charities if you
are worried about losing senate house
and exec you know presidency
you of course would give money to
support
a couple of these republicans to win so
there's a broken you know like they
don't have control of all three
why would you support oh
very strange tweet that came out about
now you know he's a good
communicator he's going to give his own
version of the story why that is but
it's nba vibe with that woke spirit that
he
and adam silver said what did adam
silver say yesterday he said what
he made some announcement that he didn't
think that the um
everything that was going on with the
social justice stuff the blm stuff
had an effect on viewership in the nba
in the nba finals which we've
you know we've seen has plummeted yeah
of course it's plummeted and
and to me you know you know how i feel
about like yesterday lebron got a 85
million dollar contract for two years
you know what's the first thing i said
the guy deserves more than 85 million
i don't agree with the way he handles
being the number one guy the nba
i can't stand the way he handles stuff i
just don't like the way he handles
politics and the way he treats
independence i don't like the way he
treats independence
but the guy deserves more than 42
million a year yeah that's that's a guy
that these are 60 70 80 million dollars
here
and i still disagree i still disagree
with you know the back story with that
contract
i think valuetainers will appreciate
this too because it's not really sports
but he did a two-year contract
because then he can be a free agent
after two years to play with his son
yeah so brawny's going to be a software
they're going to change the rules where
you can come out at the age of 18
they're going to
lebron's going to push this through so
imagine an nba team in two or three
years
will pick bronny james number one
because they know they get lebron with
it
isn't that unbelievable he might not
even be the best player in the draft but
lebron it's a package deal he'll come
with him he'll go to one more team and
play
listen uh here's here's props to lebron
james
he is ridiculously strategic
ridiculously strategic he's brilliant
when it comes down to strategy
you don't have to agree with his
policies the guy is so
strategic that guy's gonna have a long
career of having an influence he ain't
going away anytime soon after the nba
you know what came around don't you pull
up the video what obama said yesterday
about defunding the police
he made an interesting comment uh uh
it's garrick said he gave two dollars
and said uh the shirt should say pray
for adam
can i ask you a question about two
dollars do you think o'keefe
blew his cover too soon i mean he could
have continued to record those cnn
conversations
why not just release the tapes not jump
in there
and sabotage him or ambush him like that
they'd be freaking out they wouldn't
know they think it'd be an
inside job that somebody was doing it he
had two more months of recording tapes
that he blew
now they're going to come up with some
really uh you know secure way that
they're going to
say he's going to assume it's a felony
and and o'keefe one thing people don't
realize is okeeps attorneys are legit
attorneys
every time people have tried to sue this
guy he said defamation of character
he's his attorneys have gone back at him
and they've had to apologize
people have it to publicly apologize to
this guy so what's his background this
uh
project veritas james o'keefe he's uh
why don't you pull up his wikipedia
let's find out who would have i wish he
wanted to blow his cover
go to james o'keefe he was there for two
years james o'keefe uh
american activist uh go down
uh right there second one okay project
veritas uh is an american conservative
political activist
or provocat uh say that word pro pro
provocative
he produces secretly recorded undercover
audio and understanding
governmental social service organization
purpo uh perpetrating uh to show an
abusive legal behavior by employees
he selectively edited videos to
misrepresent the context of the
conservatives and subjects responses
creating the false impression that the
people said or did
o'keefe gain national attention for
selectively uh edited
video recordings of the worker of uh
workers at
american of community organizers reform
acorn
uh in 2009 his arrest and his guilty
plea in 2010 for entering the federal
office
of then u.s senator mary landrieu under
false pretenses and the release of
misleading videos of conservatives with
two high ranking now former npr
executives
interesting background they have their
own wikipedia i wonder who wrote that he
went to rutgers university ba
keep going up a little bit more keep
going up keep going up okay there you
have it that's who he is okay
uh and one of the one of the fired acorn
workers suit okey for invasion privacy
o'keefe issued an apology and agreed to
pay a hundred thousand dollars in
settlement so
he's a pretty controversial guy um
that's a biased
yeah and he ain't going that is he's
biased though is the question 100 he's
biased he is bad
of course he's biased there's no
question about him being biased
who's not biased these days who's not
biased
these days oh is anybody in a coma out
there
maybe those people i i do think there
are people who can
give reasonable feedback
you know where you can sit there and
hear them out and see what they're going
to be saying i do think there's some
people like that out there who's out
there
in this world today that is completely
unbiased
i'll give it to you i'll tell you the
walter cronkite i'll tell you who to
look at i would look at on
economy side okay if a person is coming
from a social side
there's two emotions in that but if a
person is coming from a logical side
they can reason on both sides i don't
know if i make sense or not for example
if my my issue on why i'm a democrat is
because i'm
gay and i don't like the fact on how
republican christians view gays and the
way they judge me
everything else is out the window
because socially i'm emotional i've
experienced certain things you're
anchored to that emotion
i if i have experienced racism
and i hated that one night cop pulled me
over
and you have no idea how pissed off i
was that he judged me for the skin of
you know not from a context on my
character yeah that's emotional that's
like what are you talking about do you
realize who i am
but if if there is people that are
coming from a
logical place to be able to reason and
it's numbers data
they're the ones to listen to the most
that's what i would say to you that's
why when i get my news
you know this is something that i've had
to kind of search
like i found that you know uh the
financial times
business insider even usa today
they're just giving you the numbers
there's giving you more
you know not i think wall street journal
is also wall street journal's a little
bit to the right
but i'm cool with that i would say
business insider is definitely to the
left
i mean i would not call them down the
middle not business insider
left left yeah what yard line are they
on the 35 probably they were the first
ones to proclaim biden is the winner i
mean they they're pretty anti right that
was fox news
i think i think i think wall street is
the most center
place to go to for information wall
street's center
most center place too so what place
let's get to the heart of the match what
do you mean what place like if we need
some unbiased opinion what i'm trying to
tell you
like for example for wall street journal
forbes magazine fortune magazine
fortune is all left forbes is still
center okay center right
fortune forbes forbes is center right
yeah forbes is right yeah yeah
uh uh you go to time magazine left
money magazine left newsweek left
businessweek
left washington post left washington
times
right new york times far left new york
post
far right breitbart far right the hill
left you know you you can espn left in
the middle
nobody i honestly don't i think it's
impossible
to be in the middle i think we're the
only ones i think we're middle
you you know you know why i say we're
middle what do you mean we're middle
what do you mean we're middle the way
you said it what do you think we're
middle
there there are things that all three of
us disagree on when we talk
when when when we bring other guests we
don't say like people say oh you got to
get rid of sober
for what for what get rid of for what we
need to have a trump circle jerk here
what i'm trying to say to you is
somebody
sits there and says i disagree with pat
i disagree with adam
i disagree with tom i agree with adam i
agree with pat
i then they they have to make the
decision for themselves are you saying
there is somebody that you're
are you getting away this is what
america needs right now i think every
like
even with james o'keefe yeah like i'm
using that as an example
conservative provocateur he's edited
videos
our initial reaction tom was like i
wonder who wrote that
i wonder who wrote that i'm thinking
seems a little uh
i'm not calling you out here you said
that no i did um
i'm thinking he edited videos
he edited videos right so i'm thinking
like
we're everything is so biased we're
looking it through a bias
i think you're gonna see an unbiased
thing coming out here very soon